THIRD MEETING OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE TO ORDER MADAM
SECRETARY WHICH YOU.
CALL THE ROLL SENATORS BATES.
BATES HERE MORNING MORNING HERE
RAFI.
RAFI HERE WILK.
WILK HERE ATKINS HERE ATKINS
HERE YOU HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM AND
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO TAKE A
MOTION.
FOR CONSENT ON GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES ITEM NUMBER TWO HE
THREW J..
ITEM THREE BILL REFERRALS ON
ITEM FOR SELECT COMMITTEE
APPOINTMENTS.
AND ITEMS FIVE AND SIX FLOORED
KNOWLEDGE MINCE MOVE.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN --
SAYING NO.
DISPUTETHERE MADAM SECRETARY
WILL YOU CALL THE ROLL SENATORS
BATES.
BATES AYE MONNING MONNING AYE
ROTH.
ROTH AYE WILK.
WILK I ATKINS HI A CONCISE.
THAT PASSES UNANIMOUSLY THANK
YOU WE WILL GO RIGHT AWAY TO THE
ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY ARE
REQUIRED TO APPEAR GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES AN INVITE.
I MISSED IT'S DOCTOR I BELIEVE
YES LINDA DARLING HAMMOND UP --
AND ASKED IF YOU WANT TO MAKE
SOME OPENING COMMENTS I THANK
ANYONE IS HERE WITH YOU TODAY
AND THEN WE WILL GET RIGHT INO
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
WELCOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PLEASURE TO BE HERE I AM HONORED.
TO BE ASKED TO SERVE ON
CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION -- IT'S A PROPITIOUS
MOMENT FOR EDUCATION IN THE
STATE.
MANY OF YOU KNOW THE CALIFORNIA
WAS ONCE ONE OF THE MOST
IMPRESSIVE EDUCATION SYSTEMS IN
THE COUNTRY AND PERHAPS IN THE
WORLD -- BUT WE HAD A STEADY
DECLINE FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS --
WHICH CAUSED ONE FILMMAKER TO
CREATE A FILM CALLED FROM FIRST
TO WORST TO CHARACTERIZE --
CALIFORNIA'S SLIDE -- BY TWO SUB
THOUSAND SEVEN WE WERE IN THE
BOTTOM FIVE STATES ON DOLLARS
AND STAFFING AND ACHIEVEMENT.
BUT WE'VE HAD A TURNAROUND IN
RECENT YEARS AND A NEW FUNDING
SYSTEM NEW ACCOUNTABILITY
STANDARDS CURRICULUM FRAMEWORKS.
INSTRUCTIONAL SUPPORTS GAINS IN
ACHIEVEMENT GAINS IN GRADUATION
RATES AND I BELIEVE WE NEED TO
CONTINUE THIS PATH AND I'VE
LOOKED AT A LOT OF STATES AND A
LOT OF COUNTRIES THAT HAVE
REALLY ACHIEVED ACADEMICALLY AND
THEY HAVE.
A FIFTEEN OR TWENTY YEAR PERIOD
OF BUILDING ON SUCCESS AND
REFINING AND IMPROVING WHAT
THEY'VE DONE.
A AND I THINK THAT'S THE PATH
WE'RE ON AT THE STATE BOARD SO I
HOPE TO CONTRIBUTE. TO THAT PATH
AND TO HELP US A MOVE FROM WORST
TO FIRST.
LET ME START WITH YOU SENATOR
ROTH.
THANK YOU MA'AM SURE -- ACTUALLY
A DOCTOR HAMON AND I HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A VERY
DETAILED THE I THINK IT WAS
YESTERDAY I'M LOSING TRACK OF
TIME MAYBE WAS THE DAY BEFORE.
ON OUR STATE -- CRITIC EDUCATION
EFFORTS THE LC FF AN ALLE CAP
PROCESS AMONG MANY OTHER ISSUES --
AM EXTRAORDINARILY PROUD THAT
SHE IS CONTINUING TO SERVE US --
AS A MEMBER OF THE STATE BOARD
OF LOOK FORWARD.
TO MOVING HER CONFIRMATION -- AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME
CONGRATULATIONS DR.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR POINT
AND I'M LOOKING FOR TO VOTING
FOR YOUR CONFIRMATION -- WE TOO
HAD A LOVELY CONVERSATION
YESTERDAY WHICH I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED SOME THIS CALL
THINGS I WANTED TO GET OUT THERE
BECAUSE JUST SO YOU CAN
ARTICULATED SO I'VE HAD A LOT OF
CONSTITUENT LETTERS.
ON THE RECENT AT HEALTH
EDUCATION STANDARDS I KNOW WE
TALKED ABOUT IT IF YOU COULD
JUST SHARE THE PROCESS AND IN
THE FLEXIBILITY THAT'S IN THERE
SO.
THAT'S OUT IN THE PUBLIC AROUND
MIGHT APPRECIATE OR YES I THINK
IT WAS MY SECOND BOARD MEETING
AT WHICH WE WERE -- PRESENTED
WITH THE HEALTH EDUCATION
FRAMEWORKS -- AND I THINK
PROBABLY MOST PEOPLE KNOW THAT
PART OF THE FRAMEWORKS BUT 90%
OF IT IS NUTRITION AND SAFETY
AND WHERE YOUR BICYCLE HELMET
AND SO ON BUT THERE'S ABOUT 10%
WHICH IS ON SEX EDUCATION WHICH
IS INTENDED TO HELP DISTRICTS.
IMPLEMENT THE LAW THAT WAS
PASSED SOME YEARS AGO REQUIRING
SEX EDUCATION AT FIFTH GRADE
MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOL --
THE GUIDANCE IN THE FRAMEWORK IS
COMPLETELY OPTIONAL IT IS
COMPLETELY -- UP TO THE
DISTRICTS -- WHAT THEY USE AND
FOR PARENTS -- THEY GET A NOTICE
A COUPLE OF WEEKS BEFORE THERE'S
A SEX EDUCATION -- LESSON OR OR
UNIT OF INSTRUCTION AND THEY CAN
SEE ALL THE MATERIALS AND CAN
OPT OUT -- IF THEY CHOOSE TO DO
SO -- BUT THESE MATERIALS ARE
MADE AVAILABLE AS OPTIONS -- FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
MANDATE.
THROUGH THE LAW.
WE GOT A LOT OF PARA COMMENT ON
THIS SET OF MATERIALS AND AND
WAS VERY HELPFUL ACTUALLY TO
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD -- THERE
WERE SOME RESOURCES THAT WERE
FLAG THAT WERE REALLY --
CHALLENGING -- FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF MANY PARENTS AND
BOARD MEMBERS AGREED THAT SOME
OF THOSE WERE NOT -- IDEAL FOR
RECOMMENDING TO SCHOOL SO WE
TOOK SOME OF THEM OUT AS WE
PASSED THE WHOLE FRAMEWORK
FORWARD WE NOW THINK IT'S A
USEFUL TOOL BUT IT IS A
COMPLETELY OPTIONAL TOOL. FOR
DISTRICTS USE.
GREAT THANK YOU FOR THAT -- WE
JUST RECENTLY HAD THE TASK FORCE
THAT THE CHARTER SCHOOL POLICY
TASK FORCE RECENTLY CAME OUT
THEIR REPORT.
WARNING WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS WERE
ON THE RECOMMENDATIONS.
WELL THE CHURCH SCHOOL TASK
FORCE -- GAVE A LOT OF
RECOMMENDATIONS A NUMBER OF THEM
WERE UNANIMOUS AND I THOUGHT
THAT WAS EXTREMELY HELPFUL
BECAUSE THEY HAD KIND OF
EVERYONE AT THE TABLE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN HAVE A
GOOD.
STRONG HEALTHY CHARTER SECTOR
THAT YOU KNOW ALSO AVOIDS
CHALLENGES OR ABUSES OF ANY KIND
SO I THOUGHT THAT WAS USEFUL
THERE WERE.
AGREEMENTS OF I DON'T KNOW IF I
THERE WAS A LOT OF RECOGNITION
WILL GO THROUGH ALL OF THEM BUT
THERE WAS -- SOME AGREEMENT
ABOUT WAYS THAT WE CAN
STRENGTHEN THE CRITERIA AND
CLARIFY THE CRITERIA FOR
AUTHORIZATION.
RE AUTHORIZATION WAYS THAT WE
CAN CREATE A STRONGER PROCEDURE
OF THROUGH THE PROCESSES AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IN HE STATE LEVEL.
SOME AGREEMENTS THAT I ACTUALLY
WAS UNANIMOUS AGREEMENT THAT
WHILE THE STATE CURRENTLY DOES
ACTUALLY OPERATE A SET OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE OVERSEAS US
OF CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT THAT WAS
PROBABLY NOT THE IDEAL ROLE FOR
THE STATE ALTHOUGH THERE MIGHT
BE.
A STATE APPEAL OF SOME SORT --
ONE WE HAVE A SCHOOL APPROVED
THEY SHOULD BE RUN BY.
A COUNTY OR DISTRICT THAT HAS
THE APPARATUS TO SUPPORT THEM
WHILE.
ALSO I THINK THERE WERE A NUMBER
OF POSITIVE STEPS MADE I KNOW
THERE'S MORE WORK GOING ON I
KNOW SOME OF YOU ARE PROBABLY.
IN THE MIDDLE OF THINKING ABOUT
THAT WORK AND WE WERE LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT YOU
DECIDE.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR ANSWERS
AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS ON THE
APPOINTMENT AND THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN
SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU WILL MY OUR COLLEAGUE
I TO MY RIGHT.
CERTAINLY COVERED THE ISSUES
THAT WE COVER DIE IN OUR A FACE
TO FACE -- DOCTOR HAMON AND
CERTAINLY -- YOU ARE SO VERY
QUALIFIED AND THINK I SHARE THAT
WITH YOU.
A BECAUSE OF THE HIGH THE
INTENSE -- ISSUES GOING ON IN MY
DISTRICT OVER THE HEALTHCARE AND
THOSE HAVE NOT SUBSIDED ARE I
WILL -- ABSTAINED TODAY AND I
SHARE THAT WITH YOU I NEED TO GO
OUT AND SHARE WITH THEM THE
INFORMATION YOU PROVIDED ME WHAT
IS CONFUSING IN MY DISTRICT THE
TO DISTRICT.
I IS THE OPT IN OPT OUT ISSUE
AND THEY I DON'T THINK THEY'VE
GOT IT RIGHT YEAH.
SO BASED ON OUR CONVERSATION
I'LL BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE THAT
AND IN INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH IT
GOES ON FOR YOU KNOW.
EVERYDAY SO I WILL BE DOING THAT
IN PER HOUSE SO WE GET TO THE
FLOOR I I WILL BE IN A GOOD
POSITION TO SUPPORT YOU THEN IT
WILL.
ONLY TIME WILL TELL IT BECAUSE
WE HAVE A LITTLE TIME HERE. FOR
A VACATION COMING OUT BUT IN ANY
EVENT -- WE HAD A VERY VERY --
INFORMATIVE CONVERSATION ARE
VERY IMPRESSED WITH YOUR RESUME
AND ALL THAT YOU'VE DONE IN THE
END DEDICATED SO MUCH OF YOUR
LIFE TO THIS SO.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND HOPEFULLY
ON I MANY BE ON YOUR TEAM WHEN
WE GET BACK TOGETHER THANK YOU
GOOD LUCK.
IN YOUR EXPLANATION YES.
BIG JOB AHEAD OF ME.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES SENATOR
MINING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I ALSO
WANT TO OFFER MY CONGRATULATIONS
AND THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR
SERVICE WE ALSO HAD A GOOD
CONVERSATION SOMEONE ABBREVIATED
BUT WE DID TALK SOME ABOUT.
ENGLISH LEARNERS AND UNDER THE
LC FFE.
INCENTIVE FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
MAYBE NOT TO MOVE STUDENTS
FORWARD SINCE THEY GET A
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE AS LONG AS
THEY'RE AND ENGLISH LEARNER YOU
SHARED SOME IDEAS WITH ME ON
THAT THAT I THINK WOULD BE
VALUABLE TO SHARE WITH THE
COMMITTEE HOW WE MIGHT.
LOOK AT THAT IN THE FUTURE SURE
OF ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU
REYES WAS -- WHETHER THEIR
DIFFERENTIAL STANDARDS APPLIED
ACROSS DISTRICTS FOR
RECLASSIFYING STUDENTS AND HOW
COULD WE MAKE THOSE MORE
CONSISTENT AND THEN HOW TO ME
INCENTIVIZE -- RE CLASSIFICATION
WHEN IT'S WARRANTED -- SO ON THE
FIRST OF THOSE ISSUES WE HAVE
JUST THE BOARD HAS JUST APPROVED
A NEW ENGLISH LEARNER ASSESSMENT --
AND THAT WE THINK OF WILL --
CREATE A BETTER OF MORE
CONSISTENT SORT OF EVIDENCE BASE
ABOUT WHEN.
A LEARNER'S ARE READY TO BE
RECLASSIFIED -- AND THEN YOU TO
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES IS THAT
WHEN YOU GET A MONEY FOR THE
NUMBER OF ENGLISH LEARNERS YOU
HAVE.
WHEN THEY BECOME A CLASSIFIED
AND ARE NO LNGER IN THAT
CATEGORY YOU MIGHT HAVE AN
INCENTIVE NOT? TO LOSE THAT
MONEY AND WE KNOW THAT QUITE
OFTEN EVEN AFTER STUDENTS
REQUEST BY THEY DO NEED SOME
ONGOING SUPPORT TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
SO IT MIGHT MAKE SENSE FOR THERE
TO BE A YEAR OR TWO OF ONGOING
MODEST SUPPORT FOR THAT PROCESS --
SO THAT STUDENTS AREN'T DROPPED
FROM ANY SERVICES OR SUPPORTS
AND SO THAT THERE IS.
AN INCENTIVE TO RECLASSIFY WHEN-IT'S TIME THANK YOU IN THIS I
THINK YOU ALSO MENTIONED.
THE ABILITY TO MAYBE.
MAKE SURE THAT STUDENT IS
SUCCESSFUL IN THE TRANSITION
EXACTLY NOT JUST DROPPED OFF.
IN THEN I ALSO ASKED IF OU HAD
A MAGIC WAND WHAT WOULD YOU DO
AND YOU SHARED SOME THOUGHTS
ABOUT TEACHER TRAINING THAT I
FOUND.
I YEAH YEAH I I WAS HAPPY TO
HAVE THAT MAGIC WAND I WOULD
LIKE TO HOLD ON TO IT IF I COULD
BUT I THINK IT VANISHES ONCE I
LEAVE THIS HERE -- BUT I WOULD
LOVE FOR US TO BUILD NOW THAT
WE'VE GOT A NEW ACCOUNTABILITY
SYSTEM STANDARDS CURRICULUM
FRAMEWORKS AND SO ON A SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT THAT IS A REALLY STRONG
SYSTEM.
OF PROFESSIONAL LEARNING FOR
TEACHERS AND PRINCIPALS -- SO
THAT WHEN THEY ARE TRYING TO
IMPROVE.
SERVICES FOR ENGLISH LEARNERS OR
MATH INSTRUCTION THERE IS HIGH
QUALITY READILY AVAILABLE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT -- THAT
MEETS THE STANDARDS WE KNOW --
SUCCEEDS IN THAT REGARD
SUSTAINED WORK WITH COACHING
FOLLOW UP NOT ALL OF IT PROVIDED
BY THE STATE BECAUSE THERE ARE
MANY PROVIDERS OF SUCH SERVICES.
BUT ORCHESTRATED IN A WAY THAT
WE CAN SEE WHAT WE HAVE THAT WE
CAN FILL THE GAPS WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT.
EDUCATORS WHO WANT TO DO THEIR
BEST WORK ARE NOT.
LOOKING UNDER ROCKS FOR
KNOWLEDGE YOU KNOW LIKE MAYBE
I'LL FIND THE ANSWER HERE BUT
REALLY BUILDING THAT SYSTEM SO
THAT IT'S READILY AVAILABLE.
AND WE CAN REALLY IMPROVE
STUDENT LEARNING.
AND I THINK WE TALKED ABOUT THE
CHALLENGE OFACCESS BASED ON
GEOGRAPHIC ECONOMIC DIVERSITY
AROUND THE STATE SOME TEACHERS
MIGHT HAVE.
MORE READY ACCESS TO THAT TYPE
OF SUPPORT AND TRAINING THAN
OTHERS THAT IS DEFINITELY A CASE.
THAT WE DO HAVE A WORK GOING ON
TO EXPAND THE CAPACITY OF
COUNTIES TO MEET MANY OF THOSE
NEEDS AND SO ON BUT THERE ARE
HOLES IN THEIR GAPS IS A LITTLE
SWISS CHEESY RIGHT NOW AND I
THINK FOR ALL KIDS.
TO GET THE BENEFIT OF GOOD
TEACHING AND LEARNING WE WANTED
TO BE.
MORE LIKE CHEDDAR CHEESE OR
SOMETHING HOLES.
THANK YOU AND THEN FINALLY WE
TALK SOME ABOUT THE DASHBOARD IN
KIND OF A DIVERSITY RIGHT NOW ON
WHAT INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE
ONLINE.
BETWEEN DISTRICTS BETWEEN
SCHOOLS EVEN AND YOU SHARED SOME
OF YOUR OBJECTIVES TO TRY TO
YEAH WE IN MORE UNIFORMITY THERE
WE'VE WE'VE JUST BEGUN A
CONVERSATION.
IN THE STATE BOARD STAFF AND THE
CD STAFF ABOUT HOW TO BRING
TOGETHER IN ONE PLACE THE
VARIOUS KINDS OF DATA THAT ARE
IN DIFFERENT PLACES THAT BECAUSE
PEOPLE SOMETIMES. TO EVEN DRAW
DIFFERENT CONCLUSIONS ABOUT
SCHOOLS BECAUSE THEY'RE FROM
DIFFERENT YEARS AND DIFFERENT
DATA SOURCES AND SO ON AND
RATIONALIZE THAT MAKE IT.
A PERHAPS THE SYSTEM WHEN YOU GO
INTO THE DASHBOARD THAT WHEN YOU
WANT TO KNOW MORE.
ABOUT THE TRENDS IN ENGLISH
LANGUAGE ARTS ACHIEVEMENT OR
WHATEVER IT IS THAT YOU CAN SEE
THE TRENDS EASILY AND READILY
YOU KNOW MAKE A COMPARISON -- TO
THE STATE AVERAGE AND YOU KNOW
OTHER RELEVANT -- BENCHMARKS --
SO WE ARE BEGINNING THEIR
PROCESS TO REALLY SEE FREAKING.
BUILD ON WHAT'S BEEN DONE WITH A
DASHBOARD BUT REALLY BRING THE
DATA INTO A FORM THAT IT'S
USABLE BY MANY PEOPLE.
TO ADDRESS ACHIEVEMENT GAPS TO
SEE YOU KNOW WHAT THE TRENDS ARE
AND TO MAKE THE IMPROVEMENTS
THAT ARE NEEDED INCIDENTS A
CURRENT OBJECTIVE THAT'S THERE'S
RIGHT OBJECTIVE IT WILL BE AND
WE'RE BEGINNING IT NOW WILL WILL
BE.
CARRYING IT FORWARD SO WE GET
WHERE WE NEED TO GO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR MINING WE WILL --
TURNED OUT TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE
THOSE IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU WILL GIVE ME YOUR NAME
WHO YOU'RE REPRESENTING AND VERY
BRIEF COMMENTS START WITH YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR DENNIS
MYERS CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF DOCTOR DARLING HAMMOND -- ARE
WE'RE JUST SO IMPRESSED WITH THE
BREADTH AND DEPTH OF OUR WORK
ESPECIALLY MERRY OF EQUITY AND A
CLOSING ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AND
TEACHER SHORTAGE SO.
WE THINK SHE'S THE RIGHT NOMINEE
FOR THE RIGHT TIME AND WOULD
HOPE THAT YOU WOULD AGREE HANNAH
AND APPROVE THIS NOMINATION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON SMITH TRAINED
WITH CHILDREN NOW WE ARE
THRILLED THAT DOCTOR DARLING
HAMMOND HAS BEEN NOMINATED --
HER DEEP UNDERSTANDING OF
TEACHING AND LEARNING -- CUTS
ACROSS THE CHILD'S.
FULL CONTINUUM OF LIFE FROM OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS ALL THE WAY UP
TO TEACHERS WHO ARE PURSUING A
CAREER -- TEACHING CHILDREN SO --
WHERE YOU KNOW THRILLED OF HER
LEADERSHIP HER KNOWLEDGE HER
KNOWLEDGE OF POLICY FROM STATE
AND FEDERAL TO NATIONAL -- AND
HER DEEP COMMITMENT TO EQUITY WE
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HER TO LIFT UP OUR YOUNGEST
CHILDREN AND ALL OF OUR CHILDREN --
AND MOST WONDERFUL CHILDREN --
TO BE SUCCESSFUL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AND STUFF
FROM LAKE ROPE REPEATING THE
CALIFORNIA STEM NETWORK WERE
ALSO VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
APPOINTMENT OF DR DARLING
HAMMOND.
SHE HAS BEEN A ONE OF THE
NATION'S AND WORLD'S PREEMINENT
SCHOLARS IN EDUCATION FOR
DECADES -- BUT SHE'S ALSO GIVEN
OF HERSELF TO THIS PUBLIC POLICY
ARENA FOR SO LONG.
I HAVE THE JOY TWENTY YEARS AGO
IS THE CHIEF CONSULTANT TO THE
LEGISLATURE'S JOINT COMMITTEE TO
DEVELOP A MASTER PLAN FOR
EDUCATION.
I AM WORKING TO DEVELOP A LONG
RANGE BLUEPRINT AND EVEN BACK
THEN -- DOCTOR TELLING HIM GIVE
SO MUCH OF HER TIME AND ENERGY.
AND KNOWLEDGE -- AS A STANFORD
SCHOLAR. TO THIS LEGISLATURE TO
ENSURE THAT IT'S WORK PRODUCT
WOULD BE OUTSTANDING BUT SHE'S
ALSO BEEN IS.
TRULY DEDICATED LEADER ON THE
FRONT OF EQUITY HAS THE PRAYER
WITNESSING DISK INDICATED A AND
ALSO IN STEM EDUCATION.
IN HER LEADERSHIP OF THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING AND EVEN LEFT THEM
AN ASSIGNMENT TO KEEP WORKING ON
EARLY EDUCATION AND I HAVE EVER
MATH EDUCATION IN THE EARLY
GRADES. TO KEEP THAT WORK MOVING
FORWARD WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THIS WE URGE THIS COMMITTEE AND
YOUR SENATE COLLEAGUES TO A
CONFIRM THIS APPOINTMENT THE
EARLIEST POSSIBLE CONVENIENCE
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON ALICIA PRIEGO
HERE ON BEHALF OF CO DOT ORG IN
SUPPORT OF I'M DOCTOR DARLING
HAMMOND APPOINTMENT AND WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE WORK THAT
SHE'S DONE WITH OUR ORGANIZATION
FOR INCREASING COMPUTER SCIENCE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARC ABOUT IS A
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
ACCESS -- AS A PRESS SPEAKERS
MENTION WERE ALSO VERY EXCITED
TO HAVE DOCTOR LOOK DARTING
HAMMOND AS A NEW STATE PARK
PRESIDENT AD DISAPPOINTMENT.
AND WE HAVE REALLY BEING -- THE
FOLLOWING HER WORK FOR MANY MANY
YEARS OVER TWENTY DECADES.
AND SHE'S VERY THOUGHTFUL ABOUT
HOW TO ENSURE THAT RESEARCH IS
INFORMED BY POLICY AND PRACTICE
AMPS PARTICULARLY FOR ACTS THAT
WERE VERY -- EXCITED ABOUT HER
FOCUS ABOUT TEACHER QUALITY AND
HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS IN THE
CLASSROOMS THINKING ABOUT
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE STUDENT
POPULATION.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST I AM I'M
A FORMER STUDENT AT STANFORD IN
HER GOING TO SCHOOL PROGRAM
THINKING ABOUT URBAN EDUCATION
HOW DO WE CLOSE THE CHEAP AND
GAPS OF FOR THAT WE SUPPORT THEM
THAT.
APPOINTMENT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON ANDREA
BALL ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SUBURBAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND STRONG SUPPORT
DELIGHTED TO SEE DOCTOR DARLING
HAMMOND IN THIS POSITION.
WE APPRECIATE HER WORK OVER THE
YEARS THE REPORT THAT SHE IN
DAVID PLANK DID A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO JUST BEGINNING OF L.
CFF ON ACCOUNTABILITY.
HAS REALLY GUIDED A LOT OF THE
WORK THAT ARE DISTRICTS HAVE
BEEN LOOKING TO DO AND THE BOARD
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF THAT HAVE
DONE AND BEEN REALLY HELPFUL TO
STUDENTS AND REALLY ADDRESSING
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS IN OUR
DIVERSE STATE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY -- SEEING NONE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH IRA.
CALL THE ROLL MADAM SECRETARY
SENATORS BATES [inaudible]
MONNING.
MONNING I RAFI.
RAFI I WILL HI WILK AYE ATKINS
HI CAN SIGN.
OF FOUR ZERO CONGRATULATIONS AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
I'M THRILLED I FEEL A LITTLE OLD
AT THE MOMENT BUT I WHAT EXACTLY
IS A LONG TIME [inaudible]
THANK.
MAYBE IT JUST FEELS LIKE TWENTY
DECADE.
LET ME INVITE UP -- SOME
UNFAMILIAR FACES -- I'M KIDDING --
MICHAEL ALAN AND MARTY BLOCK --
WILL BE NEXT UP IN THESE ARE FOR
APPOINTMENTS RE APPOINTMENTS TO
THE CALIFORNIA UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE APPEALS BOARD.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU BOTH -- I
THINK YOU YOU'VE DONE THIS
BEFORE YOU SORT OF KNOW THE
DRILL -- MISTER ALLEN I'LL ASK
YOU TO STARTIN OPENING COMMENTS
WANT TO THANK ANYBODY.
MR BLOCK -- YOU CAN FOLLOW AND
THEN WE'LL GET RIGHT INTO IT.
THANK YOU.
YES I'LL KEEP MY OPENING
COMMENTS SHORT I KNOW IT ONE
EVEN A HOLIDAY HERE -- YOU KNOW --
I'VE BEEN VERY FORTUNATE TO BE
ABLE TO OUR SERVER ON THE
LEADERSHIP TEAM WITH THE SPEAKER
AND THEN IT WITH A A YOU CENTER
ATKINS AND INTO SENATOR MINING.
AND DURING MY TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE -- I WAS VERY
FORTUNATE TO BE ABLE TO WORK ON
THE CONDITION STATE OF OUR STATE
HOSPITALS ACTUALLY VISIT THEM.
AND ALSO TO WORK -- RUBBER
OTHERS REPRESENTING -- THE FOLKS
AT THE ON FILL A VETERANS HOME.
IN TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
VETS GOT THE VERY BEST TREATMENT --
I CAME ONTO THE UNEMPLOYMENT
APPEALS BOARD -- AT THE TAIL END
OF THE RECESSION AT AT I THINK A
LOT OF YOU KNOW THAT -- AT THE
HEIGHT OF THE RECESSION.
ARE THE OUR AGENCY WAS -- IT WAS
A IN THE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND CASES
BEING EDUCATED AT THE HEIGHT OF
THE RECESSION.
AND I HAVE SERVE NOW FOR SIX
YEARS ON THE UNEMPLOYMENT
APPEALS BOARD.
AND OUT ONE THING THAT I'M VERY
PROUD OF IS THAT -- WE WERE ABLE --
TO AS THE RECESSION -- IT DATED
AND OF PEOPLE AND WENT BACK TO
WORK THAT WE ARE ABLE.
TO MAKE A LOT OF PROGRESS IN
TERMS OF THE EDUCATION OF OUR
CASES IN A MORE RAPID FASHION.
THE APPEALS A PORTION OF THAT WE
DO AT AT THE AT THE APPEALS
LEVEL -- WE WENT PAPERLESS WHICH
MADE A HUGE DIFFERENCE IN OUR
ABILITY TO ADJUDICATE CASES
EFFICIENTLY.
AND OVER THE YEARS SO WE'VE IN A
LOT FOR THE LAST SEVEN YEARS NOW
WE'VE MET AT DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
STANDARDS WHICH WAS A HUGE ISSUE
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH.
AND WE'VE ALSO BEEN ABLE TO A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF GOOD WORK
IN TERMS OF MODERNIZING THE
AGENCY -- AND WOULD BE A LOT OF
WORK INTO THE TRAINING OF OUR
STAFF.
AND ALSO PAYING ATTENTION TO
SUCCESSION PLANNING FOR THE
ORGANIZATION -- IT IS MY HONOR
THAT I HAVE THE CHAIR OF THE OF
THE BOARD HEARING A LET HIM GIVE
YOU A LOT OF THE DATA REGARDING
THAT I'M MORE THAN WILLING TO
ANSWER ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS BUT
I WILL TELL YOU THIS THAT --
PERSONALLY I FEEL LIKE -- MY
BECAUSE OBLIGATION GOING FORWARD
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE 30%
OF OUR STAFF IS GOING TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR RETIREMENT.
AND SO WE NEED TO DO GOOD
SUCCESSION PLANNING.
AND THEN THE OTHER PART OF IT IS
THAT I'VE ALWAYS BEEN A BIG
PROPONENT OF TRAINING BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T TRAIN ENOUGH
ESPECIALLY WITH THE FACT THAT.
OTHERS CONSTANTLY I CHANGES IN
LABOR LAW EMPLOYMENT LAW.
AND THE NEED TO GIVE THE VERY
BEST SERVICE -- IN TERMS OF
FAIRNESS AND IMPARTIALITY FOR
THE PARTIES THAT COME BEFORE US
SO THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
FEBRUARY THIRD IS A SENATOR
BLOCK.
WILL ALWAYS A CENTER WELCOME
WELL THANK YOU AND AND IT IS
GREAT TO BE BACK HERE IF I MAY
TAKE A MOMENT JUST INTERESTS ARE
STAFF FOR HERE BECAUSE SEVERAL
CAME TO SUPPORT US.
IF YOU GUYS DON'T MIND IT'S LIKE
RAISE YOUR HAND WHEN I CALL YOUR
NAME BECAUSE I CAN'T SEE YOU --
ELENA GONZALEZ IS OUR CEO.
MARK -- SAM IS OUR NEWLY HIRED
CHIEF ATTORNEY CHIEF COUNSEL.
JODY REMEDY IS OUR NEWLY HIRED
CHIEF JUDGE OF APPELLANT
OPERATIONS.
ROB STILL LOSE THEIR CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER.
LAURIE CURA SAKA IS OUR
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR.
JEFF WILL BE IS OUR CHIEF
INFORMATION OFFICER ALSO
RECENTLY HIRED.
BROWNFIELD IN IS NOT RECENTLY
HIRED HE IS.
AT THIS POINT OR NOT RETIRED A
NEW CONTINUES TO BE CHIEF
COUNSEL AND CAN HIT COX'S ARE
ASSISTING COUNSEL SO THOSE ARE
STAFF AND I WANT TO THANK THEM
ALL FOR SUPPORTING US AND TING
OM DEM OFFER WHAT THEY DO.
TO MAKE MICHAEL AND MYSELF
SUCCESSFUL IS THE BOARD MEMBERS --
VERY BRIEFLY JUST FOR SOME
CONTACTS WE ARE AN INDEPENDENT
ADMINISTRATIVE COURT SYSTEM AND
WE'RE SET UP SOLELY TO PROTECT
THE RIGHTS OF WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS WHEN IT COMES TO
DECISIONS MADE ON UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS DISABILITY BENEFITS.
AND PAYROLL TAX DECISIONS WHEN
THOSE DECISIONS ARE MADE AND
THEY'RE MADE BY E. D. D..
BUT ANY OF THE PARTIES DISAGREE
WITH THE DECISION SAY THAT
APPEAL TO SEE WHY AB WHICH IS
OUR ORGANIZATION. TO GIVE YOU
SOME CONTEXT LAST WEEK I
ATTENDED THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION FOR FOLKS TO DO WHAT
MICHAEL AND I DO.
AND WE ARE HUGE WE WE ALL KNOW
CALIFORNIA STANDS OUT FROM OTHER
STATES BUT ONE OUT OF EVERY FIVE
YOU AYE CLAIMS.
IN THE COUNTRY COM OUT OF
CALIFORNIA ONE OF EVERY.
FIVE IN THE CASE LOAD FOR OUR
ORGANIZATION IS GREATER THAN THE
COMBINED CASELOAD OF THE THIRTY
SMALLEST STATES IN THE UNION PUT
TOGETHER.
SO -- WE DO A LACK WERE BIG --
I'LL GIVE YOU SOME NUMBERS THAT
ARE KIND OF ANNUALLY AVERAGES
ARE NOT EXACT FOR LAST YEAR BUT
OVER THE LAST FOUR FIVE YEARS.
WE HAVE ABOUT TWO MILLION
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE CLAIMS
FILED ANNUALLY THOSE ARE FILED
WITH THE EDT. EIGHTY D. MAKES A
DETERMINATION AS TO WHETHER
SOMEONE IS QUALIFIED FOR
EMPLOYMENT OR NOT.
AND 90% OF THOSE SCHOOL ALONG
WITH EDIE'S DETERMINATION.
THAT 10% WHO DISAGREE I THOUGHT
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND EITHER
PARTY CAN FILE WITH OUR OFFICE A
AN APPEAL.
AND IT GOES TO ONE OF THIRTEEN
DISTRICT OFFICES AROUND THE
STATE.
AND WE HAVE A JAY'S ADMINISTERED
Là JUDGES IN THOSE THIRTEEN
OFFICES AND THEY WILL DECIDE HOW
AND THOSE APPEALS -- OF THOSE.
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND THIS
APPELLATE DECISIONS MADE BY OUR
OUR FIELD JUDGES ABOUT 10% ABOUT
TWENTY THOUSAND AND UP NOT
AGREEING WITH THAT OUTCOME.
AND THOSE TWENTY THOUSAND FILE A
SECOND LEVEL OF PEEL WHICH COMES
TO OUR BOARD MICHAEL AN IDEA AND
REDUCES SOME OF YOU KNOW.
AND TWO OTHER BOARD MEMBERS --
THE FIVE OF US STAND DETERMINE
ON THOSE TWENTY THOUSAND CASES
WHAT THE FINAL DECISION SHOULD
BE.
AND I THINK FINAL DECISION IS
FINAL DECISION WITHIN OUR
ORGANIZATION.
BECAUSE ALL OF THE PARTIES TO
HAVE A RIGHT TO GO FROM US TO
SUPERIOR COURT IF THEY DISAGREE
WITH OUR DECISION.
AND I'M PLEASED TO SAY LAST YEAR
OUT OF TWENTY THOUSAND APPEALS
THE CAME TO US.
FEWER THAN TWENTY DISAGREE WITH
OUR DECISION WENT TO THE
APPELLATE COURT AND OF THOSE
TWENTY ONLY TWO TO TWO TO THREE
ONE ONE CASE IS STILL IN FLUX --
WERE OVERTURNED.
SO WHEN YOU STARTED WITH TWO
MILLION CASES FILED IN
CALIFORNIA -- TWO MILLION CLAIMS
AND TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND COME TO
OUR ORGANIZATION TO SEE THAT
ONLY TWO ENDED UP NAPPING
RESOLVED TO THE SATISFACTION THE
PARTIES -- WITHIN OUR SYSTEM
SAYS GREAT THINGSI THINK
CALIFORNIA AND FOR THE WORK THE
FOLKS BEHIND ME DO BECAUSE AGAIN.
WE HEAR CASES BUT THEY DO THE
BULK OF THE WORK IN THE FOX THEY
SUPERVISE.
JUST BRIEFLY -- WHEN I GO AROUND
THE STATE AND TALK TO OUR JUDGES
I TALK ABOUT THREE THINGS THAT
WE NEED TO BE FAST WE NEED BE
FAIR AND WE NEED TO BE FRIENDLY?
AND I MEAN IT'S IMPORTANT TO BE
SPEED BECAUSE THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO LOSE THEIR JOBS OR EMPLOYERS
WHO ARE PUTTING OUT MONEY HAND
TODAY SOMETIMES ND SMALL
BUSINESSES CAN'T REALLY AFFORD.
THEY NEED A FAST DECISION AS TO
WHETHER IT'S AN APPROPRIATE --
AWARD OF UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
AND WE ARE FAST IN FACT FOR THE
LAST -- SIX YEARS WE MET EVERY
SINGLE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
TIMELINESS STANDARD.
WHEN IT COMES TO BEING FAIR
WE'VE MET FOR THE LAST FOURTEEN
YEARS EVERY DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
QUALITY STANDARDS?
I THINK WHAT SPEAKS TUB
FRIENDLINESS BECAUSE OUR JUDGES
WE STRESSED OUR JUDGES TREAT
PEOPLE WITH DIGNITY AND RESPECT
BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH I'M NOT
EVERYBODY CAN AGREE IF THEY LOSE
A CAR NOT GONNA LIKE THE
DECISION.
IF THEY FEEL THEY HAVE THEIR
FAIR DAY IN COURT IF THEY FEEL
THEY'VE BEEN INSPECTED THEY
PROBABLY WON'T APPEAL AND THAT'S
WHY ARE PUBLIC NUMBERS ARE SO
LOW -- SO THAT'S WE STRIVE TO DO
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN ANY
QUESTIONS.
THAT WAS ABOUT THE BEST OVERVIEW.
I THINK I'VE EVER HEARD -- A
VERY CONDENSED THANK YOU.
MISTER BLOCK -- I HAVE TO STEP
DOWN STAIRS TO SEE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE I'M GONNA ASK
THE VICE CHAIRMAN TO TAKE OVER.
AND SHOULD YOU BE SO CONCISE AND
GONE BEFORE I COME BACK HI MY
VOTE WILL BE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
OF BOTH OF YOU.
OF COURSE -- I KNOW WILL HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT BUT I DON'T WANT
YOU TO MISUNDERSTAND WHY I HAVE
TO STEP AWAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SO GO TO
QUESTIONS FROM THE CAN --
COMMITTEES THAT ARE MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR AND
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU BOTH FOR
YOUR CONTINUED SERVICE TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
MR ALLEN YOU'VE BEEN ON THE
BOARDS SO HAVE YOU MISTER
BACCHUS CHAIR A LITTLE LESS TIME
THAN MISTER ALLEN.
LET ME START.
WITH YOU MISTER ALLEN WITH THE
QUESTION WE DISCUSSED WHEN WE
WHEN WE MET THE OTHER DAY -- YOU
BRING A UNIQUE.
SKILL SET AS AN RN AS AN
ATTORNEY.
AS SOMEBODY WHO'S REPRESENTED
LABOR BUT ALSO REPRESENTED --
ORGANIZATIONS AND THEN THE WORK
IN THE LEGISLATURE WITH DIVERSE
CONSTITUENT GROUPS.
HOW DO YOU FIND THE BALANCE
BETWEEN EMPLOYEE AND EMPLOYER
RATES?
WELL ESSENTIALLY I I THINK THAT
ANYBODY WHO'S ACTUALLY JUDICATA
CASE IS NOT THE FIRST OF ALL YOU
HAVE TO GET THE FACTS CORRECT.
EXAMINE THE FACTS MAKE SURE
YOU'RE YOU'RE CERTAIN THAT YOU
HAVE THE FACTS UNDERSTOOD AND
THAT THERE ARE CORRECT AND THEN.
THE SECOND PART IS ESSENTIALLY
TO MAKE SURE YOUR APPLYING THE
APPLICABLE LAW THROUGH THOSE
FACTS.
IF YOU DO THAT -- IN A SENSE
BEING BLIND TO WHETHER IT WILL --
WHO WERE THE PARTIES BUT BUT
LOOKINGAT THE AT THE FAX IN THE
IN THE APPLICABLE LAW USUALLY
COME UP?
A WITH THE RIGHT DECISION WE ARE
FORTUNATE IN THE IN THE SENSE
THAT WE WE DO HAVE ACCESS TO
TRANSCRIPT AND ACTUAL RECORDINGS
OF THE HEARINGS.
AND MANY TIMES THAT IS HELPFUL
WHEN THERE SEEMS TO BE A VERY
CLOSE CALL TO BE ABLE TO RELY ON
THOSE ESPECIALLY THE HEARINGS AT
TIMES.
WE WERE VERY FORTUNATE TO GET A
GRANT WILL WE JUST RECENTLY
UPGRADED OUR OUR ARE --
RECORDING DEVICES WHICH REALLY
HAS IMPROVED OUR ABILITY TO HEAR
THE TRANSCRIPTS BUT IN THE END
IN A NUTSHELL THE THAT'S THE WAY
I APPROACH THE CASES BECAUSE I
FOUND -- AND THAT'S WAY WITH MY
FELLOW BOARD MEMBERS WHEN THEY
COME ON THE NEW ONE TAKE A TEACH
THEM BECAUSE IT'S HARD TO GO
WRONG WHEN YOU REALLY PAY
ATTENTION TO THE FACTS AND
APPLICABLE LAW.
THANK YOU.
IN A FOR MR BLOCK ALSO AS AN
ATTORNEY AND AS AN ADMINISTRATOR
IN HIGHER EDUCATION.
NOW YOU'RE PLAYING NOT ONLY A
CANNELLA JUDICIAL REQUIRES A
JUDICIAL ROLE THAT YOU'RE ALSO.
KIND OF THE CHIEF -- OFFICER OF
OF THE APPEALS BOARD IN IN IN
THE AGENCY.
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE THE TRACK
RECORD YOU SHARED OF THE AGENCY
OR THE BOARDS HISTORY IS IS VERY
IMPRESSIVE?
MOVING FORWARD -- AND MISTER
ALLEN MENTIONED 30% OF STAFF
EMPLOYEES INCLUDING ALE JAY'S
GETTING READY FOR RETIREMENT.
HOW ARE YOU ANTICIPATING THAT
LOSS AND MAYBE COMBINED WITH
THAT ADDRESS A LITTLE BIT WHAT
HAPPENS?
IF WE DO FACE ANOTHER RECESSION
IN A SPIKE IN DEMAND ON ET DE
SERVICES.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
CENTER.
WE ARE A COUNTER CYCLICAL AT IS
WHEN THE ECONOMY IS GOOD WE HAVE
MANY FEWER COME PEOPLE PLAN FOR
EMPLOYMENT.
WHEN THE ECONOMY IS BAD HER CASE --
GOES WAY UP AND THERE'S NOT THE
TAX DOLLARS TO SUPPORT THE CASES
WE GET SO IT IS A CONCERN BOTH
SUCCESSION PLANNING AND PLANNING
FOR AN ECONOMIC TURNAROUND
RECESSION.
WHAT ARE WE DOING A COUPLE OF
THINGS FIRST OF ALL OUR
TECHNOLOGY HAS BEEN -- PRETTY
MUCH IN THE TWENTIETH CENTURY WE
NEED TO MOVE T TO THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY AND WE'RE WORKING
NOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY.
I KNEW SYSTEMS TO UTILIZE TO
WILL BRING US INTO THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THEM IN A LOT OF A
LOT OF HORROR STORIES ABOUT
STATE ENTITIES THE TRY TO
UPGRADE THEIR TECHNOLOGY AND
FAIL -- THAT'S WHY WE DECIDED
NOT TO TRY TO GO ON OUR OWN WITH
OUR NEW TECHNOLOGY ALSO JEFF
WILL BE TO WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
PARTNERS TECHNOLOGY MAKE SURE WE
GET THE BEST AND BRIGHTEST FOLKS
IN THE STATE WORKING AT WE'RE
ALSO SMALL ORGANIZATION SO.
THE LIKELIHOOD OF ARE HAVING
MAJOR PROBLEMS IS SMALLER -- IN
ADDITION TO UPGRADING OUR
TECHNOLOGY WHICH WILL HELP US
MORE EFFICIENTLY HANDLE CASES
WE'VE ALSO SENT ALL OF OUR
MANAGERS TO SIX SIGMA TRAINING
THE LEAN SIX SIGMA TRAINING.
WHICH THE WHOLE PURPOSE THERE
REALLY IS CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT
HOW TO CUT DOWN ON WASTE IN THE
ORGANIZATION TERMS OF
INEFFICIENCIES IN STEPS YOU TAKE
THAT DON'T.
HELP YOU GET TO YOUR GOAL -- SO
THOSE MANAGERS ARE ALL NOW AND
WILL CONTINUE TO BE TRAINED IN
HOW TO MORE EFFECTIVELY DO WHAT
WE NEED TO DO -- ADDITIONALLY
WE'RE ALREADY PREPARING A TEST
FOR NEW EMPLOYEES EVEN THOUGH WE
DON'T NEED TO NEW EMPLOYEES
RIGHT NOW WE ONE HAVE THE TEST
READY TO GO SO THAT.
YOU NEED TO TAKE A TEST TO
BECOME A AN ALJ AN
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE WE WANT
TO HAVE THAT READY TO GO WHEN WE
SEE THE ECONOMY STARTING TO
DOWNTURN WE'RE ALSO VERY CLOSELY
LIKE ALL OF YOU FOLLOWING
ECONOMIC FIGURES SO THAT WE WILL.
HAVE HOPEFULLY A JUMP RIGHT IN
THE SOON AS THE ECONOMY STARTS
TO TURN WE'LL GET ON IT.
LESLIE WE'RE TRYING TO BECME
MORE CONSUMER FRIENDLY AGAIN
WITH TECHNOLOGY IN THAT.
RATHER THAN HAVING A LOT OF BY
EMAIL COMMUNICATION WITH OUR
WITH THE PARTIES WITH THEIR
CONSTITUENT GROUPS WE'RE TRYING
TO BE ALMOST TOTALLY ONLINE
WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO DEVELOP A
WEB PORTAL.
THAT WILL ALLOW PEOPLE TO JUST
GO ON TO OUR WEBSITE AND BE ABLE
TO SEE THEIR DOCUMENTS SEE WHAT
THEY NEED TO TURN AND RIGHT AWAY
THEY'LL GET THEIR DECISIONS
RIGHT AWAY. FOR THOSE WHO DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY
BECAUSE WE'RE WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE.
WE'RE GOING TO PROVIDE IN OUR
OFFICES AROUND THE STATE KEY
ASKS THE FOLKS CAN COME IN AND
USED TO ACCESS THE TECHNOLOGY.
ALONG WITH TRAIN STAFF DOWN THE
ROAD TO HELP THEM ACCESS TO
TECHNOLOGY SO THOSE ARE THE
THINGS WE'RE DOING HAVING SAID
THAT.
YOU KNOW WHEN THE ECONOMY TURNS
AROUND OUR MOST OF OUR DOLLARS
COME FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
NOT THE STATE AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TENDS TO RUN A YEAR
OR TWO BEHIND.
IN TERMS OF FUNDING.
OF COURSE IS THE NEED TO FIND.
OUT LIKE MANY OF US EXPERIENCE
WE FIRST CAME IN THE LEGISLATURE
IT'S COULD BE HIRED THE FIRST
TWO YEARS AND WE'RE WE KNOW
WHAT'S GONNA BE HARDWARE READY
FOR THE CHALLENGE AND WE'LL.
WE'LL DO WHAT WE CAN TO BE READY.
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH AND AGAIN.
I SHARE THE PRO TEM'S THINKING
OF THE THOROUGHNESS OF BOTH OF
YOUR ANSWERS IN.
KIND OF MY TAKE AWAY YOUR
ENTHUSIASM FOR THE WORK IN FOR
THE ENTITY AND I THINK IT'S IT'S
CONTAGIOUS AND THAT NEEDS TO
COME FROM THE TOP IN.
SOME OF THE WHAT'S THE CORRECT
WORD DEANNA TRANSITIONS THAT
YOU'VE HELPED OVERSEE WAS SOME
OF YOUR LEADERSHIP TEAM.
I THINKER ALSO INVIGORATING --
FOR THE WHOLE.
DEPARTMENT SO -- I THINK WE'RE
VERY LUCKY TO HAVE YOU BOTH IN
THE POSITIONS THAT YOU ARE I'LL
BE SUPPORTING.
YOUR CONFIRMATIONS TODAY IN
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SERVICE THE CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU CENTER.
THANK YOU CENTER MINING SENATOR
BATES.
WELL MISTER ALLEN MISTER BLOCK I
DON'T THINK I HAVE A QUESTION
LEFT ASK YOU AND I'M.
I THINK OUR BOARD IS AN
INCREDIBLY GOOD HANDS BUT
SOMETHING DID COME TO MIND WHEN
YOU MENTIONED.
THE APPEAL PROCESS -- IN THE ON
GOING INTO THE APPEALS COURT.
DOES THAT SUGGEST IN THERE ONLY
TO IF I REMEMBER WHAT YOU SAID
TO MR BLOCK.
DOES THAT SUGGEST ANY CHANGE IN
THE LAW IS YOU'RE LOOKING MATTER
TRANS IN TERMS OF THE APPEALS.
BY CHANGING THE ELIGIBILITY LOS
I GUESS THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING
IS THAT DO YOU REVIEW THAT IN
TERMS OF ANY.
TRANSSEXUAL YEAH THING DURING
THE RECESSIONAL PERIOD WHERE
PEOPLE ARE GETTING PRETTY
DESPERATE AND MAYBE THE CLAIMS
GO UP.
MAYBE LAWS COULD BE A LITTLE
MORE DISCRETIONARY I DON'T KNOW
I'M JUST THINKING OF THE
COMPLAINTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MINIMAL BY THE WAY THAT HAVE
COME TO MY OFFICE FOR PEOPLE.
WHO HAVE BEEN DENIED
[inaudible]
I'M.
YOU KNOW THAT THE TREND WE'RE
SEEING I THINK IF IF THERE ARE
ANY IS PROBABLY AN INCREASE IN
CASES RELATED TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CLAIMS WITH THE THE
ME TOO MOVEMENT AND NOTORIETY
THAT'S GOTTEN.
MORE PEOPLE WE HAD A CASE
RECENTLY WHERE A PARTY LAUGHTER
EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE SHE WAS BEING
HARASSED THE LOWER LEVEL JUDGE.
DEEMS IT WAS A VOLUNTARY QUIT
WHICH MEANT SHE WOULDN'T GET
UNEMPLOYMENT HE CAME TO THE
BOARD THE BOARD OVER KERN THEY
AND WE SAID THE NO IT'S NOT
VOLUNTARY SHE'S BEING HARASSED.
HE'S BEING FORCED TO QUIT SO
THAT THAT'S KIND OF THE TREND IS
FIRST CASE THE GO TO THE
SUPERIOR COURT.
THERE IS TIED HAVEN'T SEEN A
DIFFERENCE OVER OVER THE YEARS
IT'S USUALLY ON ISSUES LIKE THAT
WHERE ONE PARTY CLAIMS
MISCONDUCT OR VOLUNTARY QUIT THE
OTHER PARTY SAYS NO.
AND THEY JUST DISAGREE WITH OUR
DECISION -- AND AGAIN WHEN IT'S
LIKE TWO OR THREE OUT OF TWENTY
THOUSAND IT'S IT REALLY I THINK.
SAYS GOOD THINGS FOR THE WORK
WE'RE DOING.
IT WELL I WILL BE SUPPORTING
BOTH OF YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR.
THANKS.
THANK YOU SIR BATES.
SENATOR ROBB THANK YOU MISTER
VICE CHAIR GERMAN
CONGRATULATIONS.
MISTER CHAIR GOOD TO SEE YOU
AGAIN IT IS THE SENATE ROTH I
JUST WAS -- MAX HE WAS GOING TO
ASK A QUESTION BUT I WAS JUST
CURIOUS WHEN YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE ANTICIPATED.
RETIREMENTS WITHIN YOUR A. L. J.
CADRE ARE YOU ABLE TO CALL ON A
RETIRED TO ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGES.
AND BRING THEM BACK AS A NEW IT
TENDS TO HANDLE YOUR DENTAL
SURGES YES IN FACT ONE OF THE
FOLKS ARE BEHIND ME RALPH HILTON
ISN'T INTO IT INTO.
HAS COME BACK TO HELP US MORE
MORE WITH.
LEGAL ISSUES FOR THE BOARD THEN
AS AN ALJ WE HAVE SEVERAL A
JAY'S WHO.
ARE RETIRED NOW AND CAN COME
BACK -- WE BEAT WHEN WHEN THE
ECONOMY WENT FROM BEING VERY BAD
AND WE NEED TO LOTS OF LG'S TO
BEING.
VERY GOOD AND WE DON'T NEED AS
MANY -- WE ACTUALLY HAD A LAYOFF
SO A LOT OF THE FOLKS WERE LAID
OFF WE LAID OFF NOT BECAUSE THEY
WANT COULD BECAUSE THERE JUST
WASN'T WORK.
AND WE'RE HOPING THAT MANY OF
THEM ARE.
CHOMPING AT THE BIT TO COME BACK.
TO BE GREAT.
WELL AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
A LOOK FORWARD TO MOVING THE
CONFIRMATION.
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK
YOU CENTER.
THANK YOU SIR ROTH I HAVE NO
QUESTIONS AT REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE THEY'LL REVIEW
THAT WAS THAT WAS VERY WELL DONE.
I DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN THE
AUDIENCE THAT WOULD LIKE TO COME
AND SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
YOU COME ALL THIS WAY AND THEN
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM CENTER ON SENATORS FAITHS.
BATES AYE MONNING MONNING AYE
ROTH ROTH I'D WILL HI WILK I
ATKINS.
LEAVE IT OPEN AND WE ARE WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE PRO TEM
BUT CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU BOTH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
COMMENT.
YOU KNOW OF THE JOBS REGARDING
OUR CHAIR -- HE MIGHT HURT THE
SAW SOME -- COACHES WITH SPORTS
HE WILL TALK ABOUT THIS BUT
WITHOUT.
WITH MARTY BLOCKY HE ST IF
YOU'RE NOT GETTING BETTER YOU'RE
GETTING WORSE AND HE'S HE'S
ALWAYS PUSHING FOR US THE
ENVELOPE TO TRY TO GET BETTER
WITH THE AGENCY AND I JUST THINK
THE WORLD OF OUR CHAIR THANK YOU
[inaudible]
A DIFFICULT.
THE NUMBER THAT SECOND SESSION
NOW WE'VE GOT [inaudible]
ONE RIGHT HERE.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE NOW GOING TO
MOVE TO ITEM ONE D. CRAIG
SPELLINGS FOR A MEMBER WORKERS
COMPENSATION APPEALS BOARD.
IT'S JUST ALWAYS WELCOME THANK
YOU.
YOU MAY EMAIL PROCEED OKAY OF
YOU DON'T MIND JUST LIKE TO
INTRODUCE TWO VERY IMPORTANT
PEOPLE TO ME -- CAMEA LONG WAY
JUST TO SUPPORT ME -- MY
MOTHER'S JOINT THIS IS JOY
STICKS WAITED.
HEN MY WIFE ON AGREED.
SO -- THAT'S WHAT THEY TO
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE RULES%
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
APPEAR TODAY -- THIS APPOINTMENT
HAS BEEN THE HIGHEST HONOR OF MY
TWENTY YEAR LEGAL CAREER.
I KNOW THAT MY STATES HAS
BROUGHT ME THIS FAR BUT I WANTED
TO STAY CALL THE FAMILY AND
FRIENDS WHO SUPPORTED ME IN MY
LIFE AND HELP ME TO GET TO THIS
MOMENT.
THIS OCCASION IS ALSO DEEPLY
PERSONAL TO ME -- AS ONE OF THE
FEW AFRICAN AMERICAN LAWYERS TO
BE APPOINTED COMMISSIONER -- I
HOPE THAT I CAN BE AN
INSPIRATION TO OTHER YOUNG BLACK
BOYS WHO MAY HAVE NEVER
CONSIDERED A CAREER IN THE LAW --
IF I'M CONFIRMED I PROMISE TO DO
MY VERY BEST TO SERVE THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA -- WITH LEGAL
COMPETENCE AND A STRONG SENSE OF
INTEGRITY.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATE ROTH.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR.
SIR CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU.
HOW IS THE -- UTILIZATION REVIEW
PROCESS WORKING NOW.
HOW'S IT WORKING -- IT BE A VERY
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO DETERMINE --
THE EFFICACY GIVEN WHERE I SIT
NOW -- AS A PRACTITIONER -- THE
SYSTEM SEEM.
TO IT SEEMED TO DO WHAT IT WAS
SET OUT TO DO WHICH WAS TO TRY
TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS.
FOR A MEDICAL DISPUTES -- GIVEN
THIS GIVEN THE TIMING OF WHEN
THE LAW CAME OUT AND WHERE IT IS
NOW YOU COULD.
ARGUE ONE WAY OR THE OTHER
DEPENDING ON YOUR PERSPECTIVE AS
A DEFENSE ATTORNEY OR AN
APPLICANT'S ATTORNEY BUT FROM
WHERE I SIT -- I DON'T REALLY
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY OF
VALUE WAIT.
HOW WELL IT'S WORKING IF I WOULD
HAVE TO KIND OF LEAVE THAT TO
THE DETERMINATION OF SAY
PRACTITIONERS OR?
OF THE ACTUAL SHOW STAKEHOLDERS
IN THE U. R. ISSUES THEMSELVES
DON'T REALLY GET TO YOUR LEVEL
FOR DECISION OF THE BOARD NO
BECAUSE AT MY LEVEL.
I'M ONLY CONSIDERING WHETHER OR
NOT THERE WAS SOME SORT OF
PROCEDURAL HITCHES SO FOR JUDGES
DETERMINED THAT THEY COULD RLE
ON AN ISSUE FROM A YOU ARE
DETERMINATION BECAUSE THE
PROCESS WAS ON TIME WE FOR
EXAMPLE OR DEFECTIVE IN SOME WAY.
ONLY THEN WITH THE W. C. A. B.
EVEN HAVE JURISDICTION TO LOOK
AT THAT ISSUE SO I'M ONLY
LOOKING AT IT FROM A
DETERMINATION OF WHETHER OR NOT
THINGS WERE DONE WITH DUE
PROCESS THE TIMING AND SO FORTH
BUT NOT IN TERMS OF THE
SUBSTANCE OF DECIDING WHAT WAS.
MEDICALLY APPROPRIATE OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
FROM YOUR VANTAGE.
AS YOU'RE SITTING AT THE TOP OF
THE PYRAMID HERE.
BUT FROM YOUR VANTAGE POINT DOES
IT APPEAR THAT THE BOARD IS
APPROPRIATELY STAY THE BOARD
ORGANIZATION THE ORGANIZATION OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES AND
THE LIKE.
IS APPROPRIATELY STAFFED FOR THE
CASELOAD THAT HAS THAT ALSO
WOULD BE VERY DIFFICULT FOR ME
TO ANSWER I PROBABLY HAVE TO
DEFER THAT TO YOU EITHER THE
CHIEF JUDGE.
OR POTENTIALLY THE CHAIR OF THE
BOARD BUT IN MY POSITION
ESPECIALLY HAVING BEEN ON THE
BOARD ONLY ABOUT FIVE OR SIX
MONTHS WOULD BE.
VERY DIFFICULT FOR ME TO MAKE
THAT KIND OF DETERMINATION
REALIZE OUR DIFFICULT QUESTION.
WELL AGAIN THOUGH THOSE ARE ALL
THE ONES THAT I CAN THINK OF AT
THIS POINT I APPRECIATE YOUR
SERVICE AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
MOVING YOUR CONFIRMATION AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU SENATOR.
THANK YOU CENTER OFF CENTER
MINING.
YES THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR
AND AGAIN MR SOMETHING'S
CONGRATULATIONS AND ENJOYED OUR
CHANCE TO GET A LITTLE BETTER
ACQUAINTED AND LEARN ABOUT SOME
OF YOUR WORK IN.
SHARED INTERESTS.
SO A QUESTION ASKED EARLIER
PANEL YOU COME FROM A DEFENSE
BACKGROUND IN THE WORKERS COMP
SYSTEM.
NOW YOU'RE IN IN DIFFERENT ROLE
HOW DO YOU -- BRING NEUTRALITY
AND OBJECTIVITY TO YOUR CURRENT
POSITION WITH YOUR EXPERIENCE ON
THE DEFENSE SIDE OF THE LEDGER.
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION -- THE
MAIN THING FOR ME TO DO IS TO
JUST REMEMBER MY ROLE.
OF MY ROLE IS TO LOOK AT HE
CASES BROUGHT BEFORE ME. TO
DETERMINE IF THE JUDGES WHO'VE
MADE A DECISION HAVE DONE SO
APPROPRIATELY INTERPRETING THE
LAWS AS THEY SHOULD BE
INTERPRETED -- THAT ALL THE
PARTIES HAVE MADE THEIR
ARGUMENTS IN THAT WE'VE FAIRLY
CONSIDERED -- THE WEIGHT OF
THOSE ARGUMENTS RELATIVE TO THE
DECISION BEING MADE BY THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE -- IN
THAT REGARD IT'S NOT VERY
DIFFICULT I BELIEVE.
TO BE IMPARTIAL BECAUSE I'M NOT
CONCERNED SO MUCH WITH THE
OUTCOME IS I AM WITH THE PROCESS
AND MAKING SURE THAT THAT
DECISION.
THAT'S COME BEFORE US WAS MADE
PROPERLY.
THANK YOU AND THEN.
JUST FOR MY FURTHER EDIFICATION
HOW MANY TOTAL MEMBERS ARE ON
THE APPEALS BOARD CURRENTLY
THERE ARE SEVEN OF US.
SEVEN IN IS -- VACANCY OR THAT'S
THE TOTAL COMPLEMENT THAT IS THE
TOTAL YEAH.
AND THEN OF THOSE HOW MANY
RETURNEES SIX SIX SO.
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY ARE
ATTORNEYS AND THERE'S A PUBLIC
MEMBER HOW DO THEY ASSIGN CASES
YOU GET.
CASES ASSIGNED TO YOUR SAID AS A
TEAM A MEMBER OF TWO WERE IN A
THREE APPELLATE MEMBERS SHIRTS
OF THE ASSIGNMENTS ARE MADE BY
THE CHAIR.
AND WE ARE REVIEWING CASES IN
PANELS OF THREE SO AT ANY GIVEN
TIME -- IF I WOULD JUST A NUMBER
THE COMMISSIONERS ONE THROUGH
SEVEN ON ANY GIVEN PANEL
COMMISSIONERS ONE THREE AND FIVE
WOULD LOOK AT A CASE OF THE NEXT
CASE I'M LOOKING AT I MAY BE
COMMISSIONER ONE BUT OLD.
BE LOOKING AT IT WITH
COMMISSIONERS FOUR AND THREE SO
IT'S JUST AND WE TRY TO KEEP IT
SORT OF A RANDOM PROCESS SO THAT
THROUGH IS THAT DIVERSITY
PERSPECTIVE ON ANY GIVEN CASE.
IN ANY GIVEN CASE YEAR WORK IN
WITH TWO OTHERS BUT IT IT'LL
CHANGE FROM CASE TO CASE CORRECT
RATE.
WELL AGAIN I REALLY -- PRECIADO
YOUR COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC
SERVICE AFTER SERVING IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR AND WANNA.
THANK IN A PLUG YOUR FAMILY IS
WELL FOR THEIR SUPPORT OF YOU I
KNOW THE SIR TEAM EFFORT SO -- I
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING YOUR
CONFIRMATION AN AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU SIR MONEY DOOR READING
AND ANYTHING BY SENATOR BATES
DEPARTURE SHE HAS TO GO CAST A
VOTE ANOTHER COMMITTEE OKAY LET
ME ASSURE YOU THAT SHE WILL BE
VOTING FOR YOUR CONFIRMATION
TODAY THANK YOU.
AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS I DO NOT
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS -- EITHER SO
AT THIS POINT IF THERE IS ANY
OTHER SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF
TAKE A GO TO THE MIKE.
SEEING NONE IN IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
SENATOR ROTH HAS TO MOVE THE
CONFIRMATION QUIRK CALL THE ROLL
SENATORS FACE.
MONNING. ONE HI ROB HI RIGHT I
WILL I WILL I ACTION. ZERO
THAT'S ENOUGH FOR CONFIRMATION
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR OUR
COLLEAGUES TO ADD OWNING
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU.
AT THIS POINT WE'RE TAKE A
RECESS UNTIL THE PRO TEM COMES
BACK [inaudible]
YEAH
AND SEE SENATOR ATKINS HI
ATKINS. FIVE ZERO SO THAT IS
FIVE ZERO THAT IS CONFIRMED AND
WE WILL AWAIT THE LAST
[inaudible]
ONE YEAH [inaudible]
WERE [inaudible]
LET ME.
YEAH RIGHT YEAH -- SO MADAM
SECRETARY LET'S OPEN THE ROLE ON
ITEM ONE D. [inaudible]
SENATORS BATES.
I ATKINS AYE ATKINS AYE THAT IS
UNANIMOUS.
I AND WE WILL ADJOURN INTO
EXECUTIVE SESSION FOR A VERY
SHORT PERIOD